watch Anna's George Floyd is honored
with multiple ceremonies protesters are
preparing for a new wave of peaceful
demonstrations this weekend in New York
the way police are enforcing an 8:00
p.m. curfew is leading to new
allegations of abuse and our national
correspondent Rika Duncan has more on
all this from Brooklyn we are George
Floyd I'm proud of the protests
emotional words from George Floyd's
brother Terrence as thousands gathered
for a prayer service in Brooklyn
Thursday that memorial turned into a
march across the Brooklyn Bridge in
lower Manhattan where thousands turned
out demanding for justice and changed
one of them was New York congressman
Hakeem Jeffries we've seen too much
violence too much brutality too much
abuse at the hands of the police
and people have taken to the streets to
say this time will be different
peaceful protests were seen across the
country from Boston to Chicago where
demonstrations lasted into the night and
in Seattle
protesters observed a nearly nine minute
moment of silence the same amount of
time Floyd was pinned to the ground but
the scene in New York City was not as
peaceful as the NYPD's push to enforce
curfew ended in more arrests and you can
see police barricades behind me from
yesterday's tribute to George Floyd as
for police actions the governor of New
York State Andrew Cuomo says he has the
state attorney general's office
investigating them and plans to have a
report on that completed in the next 30
days Anthony tareka thank you